obviously we came up short House
Majority Eric Cantor's primary loss
isn't just historic it illustrates why
the Republican Party is in big trouble
if it doesn't get serious about its
legislative agenda here are three
reasons Eric Cantor loss and why
Republicans will continue to lose unless
they change their wicked wicked ways
obviously we came up short despite
rhetoric about small and limited
government george w bush and the
republicans increased spending by more
than fifty percent in inflation-adjusted
terms and spending on regulations by
even more than that Cantor who took
office in 2001 voted for No Child Left
Behind Medicare expansion the creation
of the TSA and Department of Homeland
Security tarp and the auto bailouts none
of that reflects fiscal responsibility
kondisi we came up short with few
exceptions the Republican Party is
opposed to marriage equality of pot
legalization both of which are supported
by large majorities despite attempts to
paint him as soft on immigration Cantor
wanted to militarize border with Mexico
and had a one hundred percent rating
from a leading anti-immigration group
sixty-four percent of republicans and
even higher percentages of independence
support immigration reform obviously we
came up short as Majority Leader Cantor
pushed a GOP budget plan that we grow
annual spending from 3.7 trillion
dollars to five trillion dollars over
the next decade he supported increasing
military spending in a hawkish foreign
policy he pushed crony capitalist
institutions like the export-import bank
which subsidizes purchases of us goods
and services Cantor stood for a status
quo that Americans find increasingly
intolerable Cantor lost because he
personified all that is bad and
hypocritical about the Republican Party
and until the GOP demonstrates it's
really serious about limiting the size
the scope and the spending of government
they'll keep losing elections for reason
TV I'm Nick Gillespie
you